each fall the dusseldorf caravan show
whets the appetite for next year's
vacation season there's a wide range of
models on display to match every taste
wallet and potential adventure what's
popular at the moment our converted
panel vans like this Ford Transit nugget
rebuilt by Westphalia a third of all
newly registered camper vans are made
like this the canals tabbert care
revision as a high-tech field ipad
remote control streamlined design and
unpretentious high quality fittings all
work together to create a modern look
and move away from tradition the market
for classic campervans is shrinking in
Germany the calendar once Colonel
sternberg from the caravanning Industry
Association says a camper van is really
a car for the average family and
families are getting smaller there are
fewer classic average family so the
potential customer base is shrinking
another up-and-coming thing is adventure
holidays in a camper van and if the
vehicle has to Ford rivers and drive and
forest floors and deserts and then it
has to be equipped correctly
as this in your best off-road driving
instructor vente bangla says the best
four wheel drive is useless without the
right tires you might have two or three
differential locks on the car but if you
got the wrong tire you might get stuck
Thomas Vaas has kitted out what might be
the ultimate off-road camper at a price
of 2 million euros it's built on a 4 X 0
all-wheel drive chassis from truck maker
ma n it has a variable tire pressure
system controlled from the driver's seat
and has differential locks between all
the axles it can cope with pretty much
any kind of terrain the interior is also
fitted to cope with desert conditions it
provides the independence to spend weeks
on expedition anywhere the driver wants
to go law says the vehicle can climb
pretty much anything but it depends on
the terrain lose terrain is tough sand
is even harder to fall ticket but this
truck climbed sandy it was built for a
manager by who tourists the desert with
his family default since I think in the
goose and twiddle sonoma note the new
model from Faulkner is a little less
suited to off road trips but it's just
as exclusive young people ordered this
the Argo amphibious buggy air compressor
for diving and the extendable living
room make this perfect for an adventure
holiday Stephanie Faulkner says
everything which needs to be in the
truck is already there as far as power
goes it's impossible to improve but you
could order golden faucets and there are
tiles for 1000 euros the square meter
every customer can choose what suits
their tastes she takunda na sila mukesh
McCausland this avant-garde apartment is
completely independent as long as you
pass a supermarket once in a while